he was the self-proclaimed Messiah who
looked like a rock star a mesmerizing
personality and passionate Bible
knowledge combined to allow him to gain
ascendancy over a small group of
followers to manipulate them use them
for his sexual desires and prepare them
for his own version of Armageddon
[Music]
Vernon Wayne how the child who had
become David Koresh was born on August
the 17th 1959 in Houston Texas
his mother Bonnie Clark was just 14 at
the time while his father carpenter
Bobby Howell was a 20 year older drifter
who abandoned his pregnant girlfriend's
when another girl caught his eye
Bonnie soon took up with a man who was a
violent drunk they were married with the
Union lasting for just two years they
proved to be tortuous years for the
infant you would often recall in later
life how his stepfather mistreated him
when the marriage was dissolved Vernon
was taken in by his maternal grandmother
yelling Clark he grew into a likable
that mischievous child who was highly
active in fact he was given the nickname
Sputnik due to his boundless energy in
recognition of the Soviet satellite by
age six Vernon was taken back in with
his mother Bonnie had just married a man
by the name of Roy Halderman when he
moved in with his mother she was
pregnant again and in 1966 she gave
birth to Vernon's younger brother Roger
Vernon struggled in school unable to
keep up in elementary school to the
extent that he was placed in a remedial
class the other kids in his school soon
had a nickname for him mister retardo
years later Vernon recalls the effect
that this ostracism had on his
self-esteem I mean you're you know here
comes the retarded kids and it's like I
stopped in my tracks it is believed that
one of the main reasons that Vernon
struggled academically was that he
suffered from dyslexia a condition which
was little recognized at the time it was
also a stutterer it was clear however
that the boy wasn't stupid he had a
natural mechanical ability and love
nothing more than pulling gadgets apart
and putting them back together again by
the time he was a preteen Vernon's
affinity with mechanics had morphed into
a love for cars it also led him in a
roundabout way to music finding an
abandoned broken guitar and a barn he
fixed it up and began teaching himself
to play
[Music]
Vernon's are the great interest was in
religion his family were seventh-day
adventists since his grandmother often
had him accompany her to church he was
reared within the moral confines of that
way of worship which meant no chasing
after girls taking drugs or going to
teen parties while his peers were
engaged in those activities Berlin was
busy reading the Bible and watching
everything religious that he could find
on TV or read in books and magazines by
the age of 10 he was able to recite long
passages of Scripture and was giving his
own mini sermons at home as a preteen
Lenin was still a stutterer he combined
his passion for scripture with his
efforts to overcome this speech
impediment by listening to powerful
sermons on the radio and then reciting
the preachers words he would study and
emulate the vocal skills of the speaker
discovering that when he did so his
stutter disappeared Vernon's formal
schooling finished when he dropped out
during his junior year at garland high
school
the eighteen-year-old gained work as a
carpenter in Garland's it was there that
he began a relationship with a fifteen
year old girl when she felt pregnant the
girl's father became enraged he forced
his daughter to break off the
relationship and warned Vernon to stay
away Vernon was in love with the girl
but saw no option but to heed the
father's advice by now his family were
living in Tyler Texas it was there that
he approached his local seventh-day
Adventist elders and revealed his talent
to them he told them that he felt a
moral obligation to marry the girl he
was surprised however when the elders
tried to persuade him against doing so
he attempted to reason scripturally with
them only to find that they were getting
angry with him in the end they simply
ordered him to leave the church
[Music]
you
as a result of Vernon's situation not
only he but his entire family were
excommunicated from the seventh-day
Adventist Church thoroughly disgusted
with the organization he began looking
around for an alternative Church he was
told about a group called the Branch
Davidians who were based in Waco Texas
the Branch Davidians are an offshoot of
an offshoot of the seventh-day
adventists this original group was
founded in 1929 by a Bulgarian
immigrants of the u.s. named Victor who
teff originally called the Shepherd's
rods the sect was set up in Waco Texas
the group were convinced that the
apocalypse was going to occur in 1959
and when it didn't a group broke away
under the leadership of a man named
Benjamin Roden he called this group the
Branch Davidians in recognition of their
holding to the coming restoration of the
Davidic Kingdom of Israel in 1978 Roden
died and his wife Lois assumed
leadership of the church Vernon Howell
arrived at the Branch Davidian compound
in 1980 the 20-year olds had long
flowing hair a charismatic personality
and a self effacing manner he appeared
to be extremely spiritual to those that
he met at the compound holding to a
strict moral code and judging himself as
chief among sinners he turns up with his
guitar and a desire to use his music to
reach young people with the message of
the Lord Lois
Rodan was immediately taken with Howell
and she invited him to move into the
compound before long the two became
romantically involved despite the fact
that she was in her 60s Lois began to
give Vernon growing prominence as a
teacher at the compound she would give
him time in the pulpit so he could
expound his interpretations to the
congregation
Vernon's preaching style was very
different to what the churchgoers were
used to experiencing he wore a t-shirt
and jeans and spoke with illustrations
though often startling in their
directness on one occasion he likens sin
to snot on a person's finger that he
just can't get off above all he
acknowledged himself as imperfect as
weak and as a sinner
Vernon's natural charisma his unkempt
looks the down-to-earth style and his
deep scriptural knowledge were a potent
mix he purposefully positioned himself
in the light of Jesus in opposition to
the staid formulaic and hypocritical
Pharisees of mainstream religion his
was elevated even further when he began
to proclaim the gift of prophecy a few
months after Vernon had moved in Louis
made the bombshell public announcement
that she was pregnant with his child she
told her followers that this was all
part of God's divine arrangements
however she would go on to miscarry the
baby however she still elevated Vernon
as her spiritual heir and the next
leader of the Branch Davidians
[Music]
many in the congregation were in
agreement of Lois's consecration of
Vernon as her successor that there was
one who was definitely not
and that would be Louis his son George
George viewed Vernon as a dangerous
usurper who had shamefully manipulated
his way into his mother's good graces
and was now poised to take over the
leadership that was rightfully George's
to inherit over the next three years a
power struggle was to play out between
Vernon and George with the congregation
split between the two tensions came to a
peak in 1984 when George and his armed
supporters forced Vernon and about 25 of
his followers to leave the compounds at
Mount Carmel for the next two years this
group was situated in Palestine Texas
some 90 miles away where they had to
live in buses and tents during this time
Vernon put his skills into building up
his base of followers through his music
and the power of his personality he was
able to attract new members from far and
wide in 1985 he traveled to Israel with
his pregnant wife Rachel Jones he was
one of the congregation members it was
while in the Holy Land that he became
convinced that he was the modern-day
incarnation of King Cyrus of Persia he
had been tasked he claims with opening
the seven seals of the book of
Revelation and proclaiming them to all
the world backer now in common George
rodent was acting increasingly
erratically which was causing his
followers to decline rapidly many in the
compound openly supported Vernon
Howland's longs for his return Louis
Roden had died in 1986 and George was
determined to eliminate the threat that
Vernon posed to his leadership he
decided to call Vernon Al's by
challenging him to a resurrection
competition the man that could
successfully raise a dead person would
be the acknowledged leader of the church
in order to achieve her sentence and now
clearly psychotic George had a body
exhumed when Vernon heard about this he
went directly to the authorities and
later complained that George had been
tampering with a dead body he was told
that the authorities could do nothing
unless they had photographic evidence in
order to obtain the needed proof Fannin
led seven armed supporters into Mount
Carmel before they could find the
exhumed body however they were
discovered by George's followers and a
gunfight broke out in the skirmish
rodent was wounded the police broke up
the battle and
Vernon and his followers were arrested
and put on trial for attempted murder
only to later be acquitted of all
charges over the next couple of years as
Vernon's following at Palestine grew
back at Mount Carmel George became even
more irrational when one of his supposed
followers challenged him claiming to be
the Messiah
George lost control and killed the man
with an axe this act saw him being sent
to a hospital for the criminally insane
[Music]
with George now well and truly out of
the way Vernon and his followers
reentered the Mount Carmel compounds he
was now the undisputed leader of the
Branch Davidians not long after his
return he had his name legally changed
to David Koresh the word Koresh is the
Hebrew name for Cyrus who David was
convinced he was the modern-day
incarnation of with his new name came
the conviction that Koresh was more than
a prophet he was the modern-day Messiah
and the words that he spoke were of
divine origin
as the 1990s dawned David Koresh was a
30 year old self-proclaimed Messiah with
a young wife and two children he
presided over more than 100 faithful
adherents who lived together in a single
large building having mastered the
fusion of religious music and
inspiration or proselytizing Koresh's
marathon sermons could last all day and
all night
still the believers would hang on his
every word Koresh began using his
position as the revealer of God's will
to announce supposedly divine decrees
that were increasingly to his personal
advantage one of the most controversial
was that all of the women in the complex
were to be available to him at any time
for his sexual pleasure this included
all of the married women as well Koresh
did not confine his sexual liaisons to
adult women girls as young as 12 became
his sexual partners these girls had been
convinced that to give themselves over
to God in the form of Koresh was the
greatest privilege that they could
attain the men of mount carmel including
those who were married were to remain
celibate this was because there was only
one seed that was holy and it flowed
from Koresh as a result the majority of
the children at the complex were his at
the time of his death he was father to
15 sons and daughters while the majority
of the Branch Davidians accepted this
arrangement as the will of God there
were a handful of dissenters who left
the church because of it some of those
who left were Australian when they
returned back home to Australia they
went to the American Embassy and child
abuse charges were laid against Koresh
back in the United States other
defectors made similar charges in
response to the allegations Child
Protective Services sent investigators
to the Mount Carmel complex their
specific brief however was to assess the
validity of an accusation that children
had access to firearms Koresh however
showed that all of the firearms Wonder
lock-and-key
and Child Protective Services they
closed the case in the wake of the
defection
keresh became increasingly angry and
violent towards his followers when one
woman expressed a desire to take her
child and leave he denied her permission
and to teach her a lesson he raped her
he then went on to recount the incidents
as a warning to the congregation at this
time his sermons they became darker with
a constant theme of the coming day of
judgment he told his followers that
Armageddon was going to be initiated
right there at Mount Carmel and that
they had to be prepared to give up their
lives in order to usher in the Davidic
Kingdom
[Music]
by 1992 Koresh at imbued a siege
mentality into the minds of his
followers the governmental authorities
they were agents of the devil and they
were preparing for a cataclysmic
showdown with the true followers of God
who were holed up at Waco by divine
inspiration Koresh revealed that he had
been instructed to stockpile weapons at
the compound David soon discovers that
the trading of guns was a lucrative
business providing much-needed funds for
the ongoing costs associated with the
compounds he would have members buying
up cheap weapons and then selling them
as gun trade shows any excess money
would be used to build up their arsenal
meanwhile the information about the
presence of weapons and Mount Carmel had
been passed on by the agents who had
visited from Child Protective Services
to the FBI who had in turn given it to
the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms
the ATF now began surveillance of the
property the situation went up a notch
when a UPS delivery package was seen by
agents to contain hand grenades which
were illegal this discovery led to an
eight-month investigation which revealed
a trail of everything from grenade
launchers to assault weapons ending up
at Mount Carmel by early November of
1992 the ATF had amassed enough evidence
to take Koresh into custody they were
worried though that his followers who
sincerely believed that he was the
Messiah would fight to stop them from
taking him away they could have arrested
him when he was in town buying supplies
but for some reason they chose not to
instead they placed some undercover
agents in a small cabin that was
situated right in front of the entrance
to the compound one of the agents Robert
Rodriguez managed to befriend members of
the group and get himself invited to a
Bible study class where he could observe
Koresh up close
the ATF concluded that Koresh was an
imminent danger to society who could
unleash his followers and their lethal
force upon any target at any time they
decided that the best course of action
was to stage a raid on his complex the
date was set for February the 28th 1992
an hour before the raid was scheduled to
go down undercover agent Rodriguez went
into the compound and showed Koresh that
morning's copy of a local paper with its
blazing headline the sinful Messiah
alongside a picture of Koresh Koresh who
had already been informed that there was
a buildup of law enforcement and media
around the area told Rodriguez that he
knew that the ATF were
- attack upon exiting Mount Carmel
Rodriguez tried to warn his ATF bosses
that Koresh already knew about the
surprise rays but it was too late
fully armed agents were already closing
in on the compound so this day it
remains unclear as to which side fired
first but within minutes a fierce
firefight was underway more than 70 ATF
officers were secretive around the
building while army helicopters circled
above inside Branch Davidian members
poured fire on the invaders who had come
to take away their Messiah the shooting
lasted for more than 60 minutes Koresh
was hit in the wrist while six of his
followers were shot dead for ATF agents
were also killed as the fighting
continued Koresh made a phone call to
the local police department urging that
the rate be stopped the request it fell
on Delia's and he hung up and proceeded
to go upstairs it was then that he was
wounded a second time this time more
seriously the bullet penetrated his hip
confining him to the floor when the
shooting ended the ATF had multiple
casualties and no David Koresh the
handling of the raid was roundly
condemned leading to intervention by the
FBI with worldwide attention now focused
on Waco the new men in charge were
determined to end the standoff as
quickly as possible
[Music]
a final battle that Koresh had been
proclaiming for so many years was now
upon his followers with him were 117 of
the faithful including 46 children
nobody wanted to leave but Koresh sent
out 14 children none of which were his
offspring in the days after the raid
Koresh's main preoccupation during the
siege which was to last for 51 days was
to get his message about the seven seals
out to the world the raids had created a
media frenzy and he believed that he
could capitalize on the publicity to get
the word out for hours on end he
proselytized over the phone to FBI
negotiators three days after the raid
Koresh agreed to bring out all of his
followers if he could get one of his
sermons said on the radio this was duly
complied with but Koresh failed to live
up to his side of the bargain claiming
that God had told him to hold off until
he received further instruction after
two weeks food water and milk for the
young children was running dangerously
low inside the compounds Koresh told his
slowly starving followers that the
hardship they were facing was a direct
test of their faith in Him things got
worse when the FBI cut off all power to
the complex and began playing loud music
and shining blazing lights throughout
the night in order to prevent the Branch
Davidians from sleeping still the people
inside it would not budge Koresh had
been letting out a trickle of people
thus far but now he angrily declared
that no one else would leave Mount
Carmel so long as the government kept up
the torment an increasingly frustrated
FBI now brought in Abrams tanks which
proceeded to smash and destroy all
property outside of the compound
including vehicles with the pressure
tactics falling flat the FBI allowed a
defense attorney hired by Koresh's
mother to go in and talk to his clients
thresh told the lawyer that he knew that
the government would not let him live
even though the FBI had offered to
arrange for a worldwide television
broadcast of his message if he promised
to come out his trust in them was
shattered and he refused the offer there
was a breakthrough of sorts on April the
14th when Koresh announced that dalton
instructed him to write down the entire
message of the seven seals of revelation
when this majestic work was completed as
promised the siege would be over and the
Branch Davidians would come out the
seven seals offer however was never
passed on to US Attorney General Janet
Reno who on April the 17th authorized
the plan to use tanks and tear gas
to bring the siege to an end
[Music]
the end began at 6:00 a.m. on April the
19th when an FBI agent phoned Koresh and
told him that tear gas was being placed
in the building by mechanical arms
attached to tanks he stressed that it
was not an assault and urged the
Davidians not to fire their weapons the
tank smashed into the building as in
delivered CS gas inside the people were
in agony unable to breathe and feeling
as if their throats and lungs were on
fire still nobody came out after six
hours a fire erupted which quickly got
out of control now
surely on Lucas reasons those inside
would come out but it wasn't to be the
fire raged through the building killing
79 people including 22 children Koresh
had made his way to the chapel with the
flames closing in he died of a gunshot
wound to the head nobody knows whether
or not he claimed his own life so I
really hope you found the video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe and hit that bell so you get
notified when we put out new videos
normally do a couple of these every week
some of them dark like this others of
them a little more light so if you'd
like that sort of stuff hit subscribe
and hit like also check out some other
videos linked to on the screen now and
as always thank you for watching
you
[Music]